political tensions between the u.s and
china now playing out in next year's
winter olympics in beijing
u.s president joe biden said for weeks
he was considering a diplomatic boycott
of the games over china's human rights
record particularly what washington says
is genocide against uyghur muslims in
xingyang province the biden
administration will not send any
diplomatic or official representation to
the beijing 2022 winter olympics and
paralympic games given the pierre scenes
ongoing genocide and crimes against
humanity and xinjiang and other human
rights abuses the athletes on team usa
have our full support we will be behind
them 100 percent as we cheer them on
from home
china is accused of detaining more than
a million uyghur muslims and other
minorities in camps where forced labor
and sterilization of women are allegedly
common
beijing denies this before the boycott
was announced it warned of counter
measures but also talked down any likely
impact from the u.s move
those politicians who clamor for a
boycott for political self-interest are
just showing off and hyping things up
nobody cares whether they come or not
and it will have no influence on
beijing's success in hosting the winter
olympics
the boycott is moving forward despite
recent efforts to stabilize ties
including last month's video meeting
between biden and chinese president xi
jinping i think what we're seeing now is
both the united states and china testing
the waters and going back and forth on
politics and the olympics become a
platform or a proxy for engaging in
political verbal battles let's just hope
it stays at verbal we're entering a
perilous moment and the olympics are
sort of amping up the tension between
the two countries in ways that are much
bigger than the olympics
the u.s also applauded the women's
tennis association for suspending all
tournaments in china over concerns for
the safety of chinese tennis star
pengshui
with the olympics coming to the u.s in
2028 there are now questions about how
china may respond both in the short and
long term
katya lopezudayan al jazeera